hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday Morning podcast and
uh-huh checking in on you who
how are you how's it going how's your
team doing is your team still in the
[__] playoffs because mine isn't
gradually getting over this I've been
actually watching a lot of playoff
hockey what about the [__] Seattle
cracking
knocking out the Avalanche I mean that's
fun to see but then it's also like I I
you know I wanted to watch Connor
McKinnon and that kid who's the next
Bobby Orr and now they're not there
right
um
I have been enjoying watching the
Edmonton Oilers even though they lost
last night I watched the first like
period and a half before
my kids came downstairs from their bath
and then suddenly we were what the hell
did we end up watching all the The Pink
Panther
um
I like the earlier ones where it's just
you know
Henry Mancini's uh
music
but then in the late 70s ones they they
sorted they they re-recorded it
and you know what's funny now that I'm
all jaded and in this business it's like
they didn't want to keep paying them so
they [__] re-record it
you know
like Ozzy and what's her face did with
the [__] Bark at the Moon albums or
whatever they did to [__] over the
drummer and the bass player
they re-record the thing
and then uh then they added this [__]
music
I can't remember how it went it was
stuck in my head in a [__] Loop
anyway ended up watching that but I'll
tell you right now that that [__]
goal last night
I'm sorry I'm fighting off a cold here
Leon dry cider
you know what's a okay for those who
didn't see it he was like
like parallel to the net so there's no
way you can score this is there's like
[__] two inches of clearance above
the goalies
shoulder he flips it up off his back
which is he's not the first guy to do it
all right but he's doing it at the NHL
level in a playoff game I know other
guys in the NHL have done it but like
what's amazing is because like the
goaltender actually when the puck went
behind him he freaked out and he turned
around it hit his right shoulder and he
turned to the right
and I guaran [__] tell you like
like kids coming up now they're going to
learn how to stop that shot because I
was sick and he wanted to turn the other
way
he's got to bat it out with his shoulder
you know who might have saved that was
uh who is that [__] lunatic who
head-butted the puck
goaltender from way back in the day uh
he had the bird cage mask what the [__]
was his name played for buffalo
one with the Red Wings
oh Jesus Ken Dryden I can't remember his
[__] name but anyway I've been
enjoying the hell out of watching uh the
Edmonton Oilers and Conor McDavid Jesus
Christ when that guy gets the [__]
puck
and turns on the Jets all of a sudden
everybody in there looks like they're in
[__]
AAA Thunder Bay whatever the [__] you
call the minor leaves of hockey
and he just creates so much goddamn
space and everybody you see like the
defense is just like you know hold your
possession hold your possession like oh
[__] he's got the puck
and I think they just get like
mesmerized by him and then just one of
the yeah you know either dry saddle or
[__] Evander Kane just moves ever so
slightly north or south and then they're
just wide open for a one-timer that goes
in the back of the net It's [__]
amazing
amazing hockey to watch unlike what I
want
I want although how about
how about going up there taking away
home ice from the [__] Toronto Maple
Leafs
I still don't [__] understand that
if these four if
going through puberty on this podcast
when there's four games in your building
and there's three games in their
building mathematically there's no
[__] way they're taking away home ice
all right we lost the game but we're
still playing four
in our building
that's still gonna happen if we go seven
games there's still four in my building
so what the [__] are you talking so now
you won all right now it's three and
three
uh it just it doesn't make any [__] I
just think that's this stupid [__]
thing that they say to try to add drama
speaking of drama Jesus Christ me
defending
uh
I don't even watch hoop
I haven't watched hoop since they had
the safe space underneath the [__]
rim
you know the hey you can't stand here
you know you can drop off your kid at
school but you got to get the [__] out
of here that little that little Zone
there
you know once guys started dunking on
nobody and started screaming like
they're in 300 that I just kind of it's
so dumb
it is so [__] why can't the defensive
player be underneath there
I get the offensive even that just post
up
I miss that [__] the [__] battles
underneath
two seven Footers going at it
I mean that was the best [__] Kareem
posting up against [__] Parish
let him get this little Forum out as he
turned it through the sky hook that's
all [__] gone
now he's out there [__] the seven
Footers are out there shooting like a
[__] point guard we already got one
of those
I just it's it's redundant
Bill we get it you don't like the NBA
I like the way things were
back when women drank wine coolers
[Laughter]
I'm an idiot don't listen to me um
anyway
um how about the Florida Panthers coming
in and winning game one against the
Maple Leafs and you knew they would
you knew they would what are the Maple
Leafs going to do make it easy on their
fans
what are they going to be up in a series
they're always going to be crawling out
of a [__] hole
and the day they go up three games to
none you know they're losing the next
three games I'm not saying they're going
to lose game seven maybe this isn't
your parents Toronto Maple Leafs maybe
this isn't your grandparents Toronto
Maple Leafs
how many generations have gone by
I mean I feel like I have to root for
the Maple Leafs in the east
I'm not going to do that [__] thing
where I'm going to root for the Florida
Panthers because they beat my team and
then somehow if they win the Stanley Cup
it doesn't feel as bad it's got to feel
bad all right it still feels bad my
family is feeling the effects of the
loss
I'm sitting over in the corner in the
dark
Dad what's the matter you want to play
Shoots and Ladders I don't feel like it
um no I'm not taking it to that level
um
but I think as far as the um
the the West I really enjoy the Edmonton
Oilers
I like watching them play
you know what's funny is I [__] hate
Carolina
I hate the [__] Carolina Hurricanes
because I forget what year it was
they beat us in like a game seven it was
a clinching game I can't remember
and the guy who scored the goal dropped
his stick and he skated down the ice
doing like jazz hands he was like doing
Fosse
like his hands were up over his head he
was like oh
laughs
it's actually
whoever did that it was great because it
made it extra annoying that he scored a
[__] overtime goal against us
you know you want a guy to score a goal
and then act like a man afterwards you
know anyway Messier would just put both
arms up and have that stoic look on his
face
Messier had that jaw that looked like it
was made out of granite you know you
could take I mean as hard as it is you
can take when a guy like that scores a
goal but when a dude scores a goal and
then he looks like he's he's conducting
the Glee Club as he [__] goes down
you know hold that note
I can I'll never get up it is so [__]
it's such a [__] Petty reason
to not like the Carolina Hurricanes but
that is that is the reason why it's the
reason why I don't like those [__]
um
anyways not to mention it used to be the
hatford waylas
uh speaking of petty oh my God like me
defending uh I was saying uh
the dude there Giannis Giannis however
you say his [__] name ante tacompo uh
I got more goddamn sports fans right
into me
going up sorry Bill that was a bad take
okay if you're a number one seed and you
lose to a team that played in that is a
failure
you know I just think that's just such
like a one-dimensional way of looking at
that
because obviously it's a failure
obviously it's a massive failure
you know I just was looking at the
motivation behind the [__] question
which I kind of felt like the guy asking
the question was excited
you know that this [__]
giant guy that looks like he's chiseled
out of granite
had a had a failure and he needed him to
say that he felt like a failure so he
could feel better about leaving the
arena in his Honda CRX and going home
and banging a four
that's what I think
I think I think that guy had
what do they call that big dick energy
that guy had sweater vest energy
that guy had you know in the dance club
up against the wall I can't dance none
of these chicks are gonna go for me you
know if I was actually really mature
I would have empathy for the sports
writer too and not just the athlete
I always feel like those [__] those
[__] Sports writers they just they're
so close to it they're so close to the
money and the cars and the [__] and the
glory but they don't get to touch it
it just drives them nuts and every once
in a while
hey Tom Brady like what do you think can
you say that your hair is a little does
it look quite as good as it did
yesterday
do you have more of a Bed Head today
do you think you consider yourself a
failure
you know they'll say [__] like that like
it doesn't even [__] makes it's a guy
put he put [__] Milwaukee back on the
map as far as an NBA power they would
dorm it for 50 [__] years the last
time they won I think [__] Kareem's
name was Luau Cinder
Nixon hadn't even bugged [__]
Watergate yet or whatever the [__]
happened
it was a liberal conspiracy probably was
probably was
and then years later they got him back
they got the Liberals back when they
[__] nailed Bill Clinton
for [__] lying about a [__] I did
not
have sexual relations
with that woman I love the [__]
determination on his face when he when
he tells that lie
like
I mean it's actually kind of [__]
amazing his the conviction
I guess the stakes were so high and he
was just like
you know
I really feel like Hillary Clinton in a
good mood would be hard enough to deal
with the last thing he needs to do is be
like all right I stuck a cigar in a
[__]
she said he's got to go sleep downstairs
on the couch in the Oval Office
is that it's just something [__]
hilarious about like the level of that
problem at that height
you know what I mean
how he can't be like I I [__] won the
election I can't get a [__]
on the side no
I haven't earned that I mean how many
more [__] pairs of shoes are you
gonna buy
that's different is it
that yo that hurts me the way no that's
a bad argument there's really no way to
get out of it
what if you went the other way with it
I did have sex relations with that woman
I'll tell you I enjoyed it
she was young it made me feel good
and I'll tell you right now that was the
best cigar I ever smoked after
you know what's [__] up about that
is if he actually did say that if he was
that [__] honest
like he I think he would get even
conservatives would have to be like all
right man
I kind of got a ride with this guy now
anyway listen you guys have seen Hillary
I mean what was I supposed to do
um
like he's a good looking guy
I don't know if you don't annoys me is
my wife always goes yeah I don't know
there's just something about him
it's just amazing those guys like that
they just [__] they got that it
Factor
you know they could be complete dirt
bags and women still [__] like women
still like that guy
you know if he was a [__] ugly
bastard you know what I mean he wasn't
always walking around with that goofy
look I really think it's the goofy look
Bill Clinton has on his face
like he just looks like you're gonna go
have a good time but that's not going to
be that deep like I refuse to believe
that that guy went to Oxford
I really don't even know anything about
Oxford isn't it like England's Harvard
you know
and it's even a A Cut Above like isn't
Oxford like the one thing that shuts
down Harvard
are there any memes on that I would love
to see a meme of a guy from Harvard
meeting somebody that says I went to
Oxford if that really bothers them
and they find out they're a little
closer to the [__] Illuminati
but wait I thought I had ascended to the
peak of of power in the world
no I actually went overseas and I went
to Oxford
yeah
and I majored in European history
whatever they do over there
that was the one thing that I thought
was [__] hilarious about those people
the people out here
photoshopping their heads the heads of
their
talentless children onto like athletes
heads and getting in at USC and [__]
like that you know what the funniest
[__] thing was about all of that is
when they went there
they're dumb ass kids were able to
handle the curriculum
I bet Harvard's the same way at the end
of the day two plus two was four like
what the [__] are we doing here right
you know like MIT I feel like if you go
into MIT you get exposed but if you go
to Harvard
you know you can just major in [__]
literature whatever the [__] you're
majoring in I've never sound Dumber I
really I'm gonna call myself out on that
I realize that
do you consider yourself a failure
family bill
you guys are always asking me that
question
um
I actually think that back in the day if
I got into Harvard that's the hardest
part I don't think being at Harvard is
hard
you know because I've met people from
Harvard and I I've
you know they're smart
[Laughter]
but I mean people from MIT you can't
even have a conversation with them
I mean I don't even know what they're
doing they're like you know they're like
they're breaking down the universe
you know I don't I don't know what
they're doing over there at Harvard
why am I picking on Harvard and I think
Harvard's the best
you know
you know just dummies like me hate on it
but I mean that is the [__] where did
you go to college I went to Harvard
[__] you game over
and then all people do is oh would you
Daddy get you in there would you come
from yes
yes that's exactly what happened my
daddy did get me in there
my daddy can ruin your daddy oh my god
do you have any idea who the [__] my dad
is
[Laughter]
[Music]
that is one of my favorite [__] Clips
ever
I love the fire that that kid had how
much he believed it is dead I I'm going
back years that kid
um
when he got into it with the bouncer
you know they were sitting there I want
to say they all had on like
you know the date rapist loafers Ladies
If you ever go on a date with the guide
he has on a polo shirt with boat shoes
and no socks I mean
how many more signs do you need
I would just say watch your drink on
that date
you know for the love of God don't go
for a drive you know
um anyway
the way he's just like oh my God like he
couldn't do you have any idea where the
[__] my dad is like why don't why would
I know who your dad is you little [__]
what the [__] are you talking about
um
oh God that must have been so [__]
embarrassing
I feel bad for these [__] kids that
your dumbest drunk moment just lives
forever on the [__] internet and some
bald old Ginger like me can still make
fun of you about it and I don't even
know you've I wasn't even there for
[__] years later
you know
it's a tragedy it's a tragedy what these
kids are living right now you know this
goddamn technology
uh I've seen more goddamn robots walking
down the street
out here in LA
like robots
they're I think they're on Wheels they
don't have feet once they have the feet
then that's when it becomes creepy if
they're just sort of rolling around you
know
I don't find it as creepy but when they
start like walking
it really is dumb if you make a robot
that walks though isn't it
why wouldn't you just put it on wheels
I mean human beings even tried that with
those sneakers for a while remember that
you'd see some kid running and all of a
sudden he was sliding across the floor
like [__] James Brown but he was on a
rug
you're like oh my God who's is that
is that the next guy to be on Dick
Clark's American Bandstand
am I seeing Oh I always got wheels on
the back of his sneakers
why did those things go away
you know some uncoordinated kid really
[__] himself up on those
you know started heading towards a
staircase and didn't know how to stop
you know like somebody in a boat without
a paddle heading towards a waterfall
staircases are really like the land's
waterfall you know
[Laughter]
I feel like you get the same injuries
falling down stairs that you do going
over a waterfall
you know before you drown
oh man I fell down a lot of stairs
growing up
it's just it was just a part of your
childhood
um
you'd start crying your mother be like
what happened I fell down the stairs
God damn it I said that a lot why the
[__] was I always falling oh I know why
because my head was the same size it is
now when I was like eight
you know so I really had to walk upright
if I leaned forward a little bit you
know
that was it I was going to go right down
those stairs
[Laughter]
um I got a full [__] day today
trying to fight off this guy I keep
getting these I don't know I don't get
like I don't know what's going on man I
think I'm just old I take vitamins every
day I get as much sleep as I can my son
though oh my God
he's just wants to get up now
earlier and earlier
and he keeps coming into our room
and we [__] up because a couple nights
we just let them stay there because we
were too tired to get up and then that's
it now he thinks that he can just come
in
it's [__] hilarious he comes in at
like 3 30 in the morning
and gets in the bed and I'm just looking
at him like buddy what are you doing he
just looks at me I'll be like
water please
[Laughter]
and what's funny is I start [__]
laughing my ass off
and then he's looking at me he doesn't
understand why I'm laughing but he kind
of has like this smile on his face as
he's trying to figure out like why is
what I said so funny
and then the look of sort of innocent
confusion on his face
makes me laugh harder
and then he just starts laughing because
he made me laugh when he just starts
going like
he laughs and then in the end when he's
done laughing then he just goes dada
water please and it just starts it all
over again and then I can't go to sleep
you know you can't laugh your ass off
like wake up laugh your ass off at 3 30
in the morning and then go back to sleep
there's something about it
I don't know there's probably some
Egghead from MIT that can do the [__]
math on that
man that's gotta suck being that smart
it's got to be a painful experience
you know being that smart and seeing how
[__] up the world is
you know
and you start explaining your ideas to
someone like me
and I'm uh what what are you a [__]
egg what is this some woke [__] that's
my favorite thing now
[Laughter]
thing
that white people don't like now is like
what is this some woke [__]
hey do you mind taking your shoes off I
I just got the rug clean oh what is this
some woke [__]
[Laughter]
um
and you can blame the lip the liberal
white left for that for hijacking that
word and turning it into whatever the
[__] they turned it into
and just using it to try to [__]
defeat Republicans or whatever whatever
the [__] it is they're trying to do it's
so goddamn dumb
uh
anyway
I have read some dumb [__] though
somebody was saying you know they're
doing once again you know every August
like this country almost goes bankrupt
now for some reason it's June
and they're saying if they don't print
another trillion dollars
that this whole [__] Ponzi scheme is
over and then you look in the comments
and they go Biden's America right
It's [__] amazing like how
uneducated people are to this [__] and
then somebody goes when Trump was in
office there was no Wars can you believe
that
that's probably the same guy was saying
support the troops while Trump was in
office it's like we've been at War over
in the Middle East for so [__] long
that people don't even remember it
it's like no like once again you're
doing this January 6th [__]
all right conservatives for the love of
[__] God all right
if you got to do what you did again on
January 6 go to the Federal Reserve you
[__] idiots
I love that they went to the Capitol
there was probably 30 people in there
like those politicians go to work they
probably ran out the back door called
three Ubers and that was enough for all
of them
oh I'm cracking myself up today I and
you know what I enjoy people my view of
the world as I sip a green smoothie my
feet up I really am a [__] jerk off
you know I was actually talking to
somebody the other day yesterday
about
the funny ways that guys become friends
like you ever see a guy do something
right and you're just looking at him and
he's just he does something it's just a
complete jerk off move right and he does
it
and then you just look over at some
random other dude and he's looking at
you and you both you do that look like
[__] jerk off and he starts laughing
and then you laugh and then that's it
then you're friends with that guy
you bonded over the fact that you both
saw that this [__] other dude was a
jerk off
and it's almost like the lock the door
test in the Bronx Tale where it's just
like
because that other guy also
shared your opinion
that that guy is a jerk off like that's
the only common connection
like
if you've been vetted
I like this guy this guy's all right
that guy's a [__] jerk off
this guy sees that he's a jerk-off we
agree that the same types of people are
jerk-offs we're going to get along
you know
you know what Versa keeps sending me is
that that [__] hilarious kid for the
uh the fan of the Knicks
and he gets everybody to gather around
and I'll be like hey KD don't you wish
you came to the next and everybody's
jumping up and down that is literally my
favorite [__] thing in sports right
now other than watching the number one
line on Edmonton
um that's on the court on the ice my
favorite thing to watch and then
um
the uh
watching that kid do that [__] and
everybody just [__] jumping up and
down
that's I that's the thing that I I that
right there
that right there
okay is so [__] New York
and it is what makes Sports great and
that is what DJs are drowning out at all
of these [__] games
the unique sense of humor that every
[__] city has the way people dress
the way they talk like that dude's New
York accent
the level that those people love the
Knicks the the way they're jumping up
and down in that type of [__] but you go
to the Garden they don't do that DJ [__]
so that guy's allowed like like a fan
like that is becoming extinct
um it's the number one thing that I miss
at these [__] games like you know I
used to go to Laker games back in the
day at the [__] La forum
and uh it was a completely completely
different [__] Vibe but granted they
weren't that good
but I would talk to [__]
Laker fans that were there at the Forum
during the showtime Lakers and all of
that you know they were getting excited
because they had Kobe and Shaq but these
you know Phil Jackson hadn't come there
yet it was Dell Harris so those two you
know egos were clashing
but uh
it was just a completely uh
different energy so anyway oh now I'm
getting sad
um how about the [__] Celtics coming
back winning by like goddamn 30. I
missed that whole game I turned it on
like all the white guys on the Celtics
were on the court so I'm like all right
we're either getting blown out or we're
[__] blown out the other team
but um
that first game
the end of the game when we threw the
ball away when we
Chase and Tatum like stepped up
and then uh
I guess the guy with the Celtics didn't
realize he had moved up to like the foul
line and he just literally turned around
and passed it to a guy in the 76ers
uh that took me back to the NCAA
Championship game in 1980 [__] two
when uh Georgetown versus North Carolina
was the last time I saw that [__] all
right we established that I am an old
fan of sports all right this is the
podcast
this [__] cold is taking a hold of me
of course the goddamn [__] day before
I go to Vegas like I need this [__]
uh when do you need a cold Bill you're
right never all right that's the part
this is the Thursday podcast enjoy your
[__] weekend you [__] uh this be a
little bit of music in between picked up
by the great Andrew femalis and then
we'll have a bonus episode of the
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday Morning podcast thank you so much
for listening
good day and God bless America and
Harvard and Oxford
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast for May
3rd
2015 what's going on how's it going how
[__] ah yeah
um
I'm [__] wiped out the tour is over
the tour is over
Michael Corleone
Godfather Part Two over
um the Summer Wind It Came blowing in
from across that sea
so I feel like right now because it's
over uh
to touch your hair
and [__] walk with me
all summer long we sang a song and then
we did some other [__]
[Music]
oh freckles is going back to his [__]
house
his [__] house with the Leaky Roof
that he had to repair
those [__] [__] those Contracting
[__]
oh Jesus I still have one more bill with
them
it goes on and on
so call Adam Carolla
he'll kick their ass
but then you look like a sap on TV
but cause you're the douchebag
that had to call Adam Carolla because
you're not big enough of a man to tell
the contractor go [__] himself
laughs
um
Jesus Christ anyways
I'm [__] wiped out all right I don't
know what you want from me this week but
this is the best it's gonna get all
right this is gonna be me just nice and
[__] relaxed
um I am right now I am in uh I don't
know where I am I think I'm in Columbia
Indiana I know what you're thinking Bill
what the [__] are you doing there that
wasn't on the tour
that wasn't on your Southern tour
you know
Southern tour you know Savannah Georgia
Knoxville Tennessee Chattanooga
Tennessee Memphis Tennessee Shreveport
Louisiana New Orleans Louisiana
Huntsville Alabama Jackson Mississippi
Mobile Alabama spend the night in
Chattanooga Tennessee up to Lexington
Kentucky over to Evansville Indiana
um there was nothing on there that's
that said
that you were going to Columbus Indiana
well I mean I ended up here because
yesterday I went to the uh to the
Kentucky Derby
uh me Paul verzi
Jason lawhead and his dad
the Hall of Fame basketball coach
Jim lawhead we all went to the game uh
the game we went to the derby man what a
[__] great time
I um
highly suggest going that
dressing like a jackass like everybody
does big stupid hats bow ties the women
there good Lord
uh there's some [__] Phillies over
there
beautiful women beautiful women I'll
tell you they're they the [__] women
the [__] ladies dude they were
crushing it right up until the early 50s
I'm telling you
that was some [__]
decades Decades of [__] Derby
Williams winners walking around the
[__]
the uh the grandstand area
um we had great seats and uh right at
the little bit past the Finish Line we
just had the best time you know what was
[__] up was they they sold um
I don't know how to get into this man
they they were selling like standing
room only seats all right so we paid
through the [__] nose to sit in a box
right like we donated to a presidential
campaign we were sitting right at the
goddamn Finish Line little past it
little past whatever don't break my
balls come on you can see the horses
where we were at you could actually see
them
start of the race ran right by us then
they went around the first turn and then
they kind of disappeared behind uh some
of these corporate tents in the sea of
[__] sunburned Humanity that was
standing just standing on the inside
grass which I don't know why you would
do that
you know what I mean I mean why why
wouldn't you stay at home and just watch
it on TV and not sit there like a bunch
of [__] refugees in a tent city that
had no tent for you you know you might
as well have watched that watch a police
horse gallop by after a crackhead
underneath the [__] overpass as far
as I'm concerned all right in-field
seats are for [__] animals
all right unless you're young you don't
have any [__] money all right
you have a television it's on TV for
[__] free
why are you gonna stand there
although I would do it I do it at a
NASCAR race I do that in a second I'd be
on the infield because those you know
first of all what I like about being on
the infield is the [__] inertia when
those [__] cars wipe out usually
takes them to the outside wall and I
know sometimes they're bang off the
outside wall and they go to the inside
but at least they hit the wall and
they're starting to slow down
you know what I mean and you know every
once in a while the tire flies off and
somebody loses a head or two but that's
the price you pay
forgetting to sit on your [__] cooler
in the middle of the goddamn track
I actually had one of the best times I
ever had I went to the Indy 500 in like
1995 and most of you like eight years
old
and uh we sat on the inside of one of
the turns brought in this giant [__]
cooler and me and my two buddies just
got obliterated
you know watching the [__] cars goes
by it's hilarious you don't see anything
you just sit in the inside turn you just
hear
foreign
[Music]
that's all you would hear you just see
him go by right every once in a while
somebody would hit the wall in front of
you like oh my God I'm gonna see an
accident but you forgot they're going
like 200 something miles an hour so they
hit the wall in front of you and then
just go they just go flying down the
[__] track so you don't really see it
you see him hit the wall and then they
continue like another quarter mile in
about two seconds but uh it is amazing
but anyway so we got there and uh they
were selling Standing Room tickets
I get it people want to stand up you
know get in there to watch the [__]
thing so there's the level we're sitting
and then there's this giant like you
know uh
walkway and then there's the next
section
all right and and so basically the
people should have stood in that middle
section where you're walking to either
make a left to go to the higher seats or
make a right to go down where we were at
and where we were at there was two
sections
and there was like a uh in a little
skinny hallway so these [__] [__]
were walking down and they were standing
up there
right
and uh
you know all they had was these
volunteer teenage kids you know sitting
there chewing gum not stopping them so
it got to the point after a couple of
races and who's kidding who a couple of
[__] men tulips that people start
going what the [__] but everybody's
there is plot you know what I mean still
Kentucky how y'all doing I [__] hate
your guts but I'm gonna smile on your
face you know what I'm saying afterwards
you know I'll [__] I'll stick a
[__] some sort of farming tool in the
back of your goddamn neck but right now
I'm gonna how y'all doing oh that's
great where you from where y'all from no
I didn't get that experience in Kentucky
they were cool as [__] but whatever so
finally
we end up saying something
you know
well I had's Dad [__] Taps this guy
in the shoulder and he's like excuse me
sir you know we paid to sit here you
guys are standing up here I don't know
what happened all I know is it started
getting heated and I saw what Jay got
his fire from so now you know law ahead
and Versi right there so I gotta step in
granted this is the funny thing I gotta
step and dress like [__] Colonel
Sanders right or at the very least that
I played banjo in a Dixieland band I got
on a [__] bow tie with the goddamn
you know my dad owned a plantation hat
and I come in you know I didn't even
come in I never even got out of my seat
I just started John at this guy
I got yelled like a buddy
I paid to sit in this seat and I'm
staring at the back of your head so he
looks Over Me Goes what'd you say
I said I paid to sit in this seat and
I'm staring at the back of the head your
head and he goes oh yeah how do you like
The View I go I don't like it that's why
we're having this conversation right and
very quickly I realized that he wasn't
going to throw a punch yeah throw a
punch in the dirt and I'm not gonna
throw a punch right
I'm not gonna I haven't thrown a [__]
punch since like a street hockey game in
like [__] seventh grade right so with
John back and forth right
and he's [__] you know his broad
saying something I don't listen to her I
can't hear that voice it's too [__]
high up in the strategy shut up lady so
I said hey
he goes what do you get involved okay
because you're yelling at a 77 year old
I said 80 year old man I rounded up go
yelling an 80 year old man he goes I
wasn't yelling any year old man I go
really that wasn't you that looked like
you two seconds ago doing that
you know whatever and then the [__]
woman you know you know he was you know
that 80 year old man verbally attacked
him every [__] douche you know
verbally attacked him he's [__] 80.
what's he gonna do you know what I mean
although you got to watch out for an 80
year old you know the very least may be
fought in Korea you know hand-to-hand
combat you don't know what flashback
could come back next thing you know
right he's using this [__] racing
form as a bayonet
you have some problems so of course me
you know everybody's dressed all Dapper
and everything then I feel like a
[__] [__] afterwards
everything's settled down and this this
guy
who who wasn't involved in the fight but
was also standing up
with his [__] girlfriend and he had
his hand not on her ass like under it
and she kept moving it like can you stop
like tapping the back of my [__] with
the middle of your finger please
um he actually looks over me and he goes
hey Bill big fan
[Music]
I feel like such an [__] I'm like oh
yeah I'm I'm not just this [__]
[__] anymore yelling at a game
they're like oh yeah Bill Burr was a
[__] [__]
ah it's [__] hilarious so then I felt
all self-conscious like eh is that gonna
end up on YouTube
not that I gave a [__] about what I said
it was that I was dressed like a [__]
you know like I had a chicken franchise
that's the thing I was worried about
so anyways so that happens but uh so
basically we kind of did that and we
kind of scared a lot of people away
and uh then I was kind of you know
afterwards sobering up you know because
I was like you know I got to stay sober
because I got to watch game seven
of uh the Clippers and the Spurs and
then I gotta watch the pac-many Pacquiao
fight right
uh Mayweather Pacquiao fight right so
anyways um
I'm starting to sober up but I just
started thinking like ah man you know
I shouldn't have [__] done that we
both should handled that situation
better
there should have been some excuse me if
you don't mind and [__] like that and I
was thinking about it and then somebody
finally was just talking to me about the
derby
uh this lady and she goes uh who's kid
who this is just a really well-dressed
[__] show
and I laughed because I was kind of
sitting there fighting the feeling that
as fancy as this was as legendary as all
this is this event at the end of the day
you just kind of go into the track
you know what I mean this is really
we're just betting on the dogs whatever
they're horses you know but anyways
um
so what have we start betting races and
of course I'm losing of course I'm
losing the [__] track has been open
for over 140 [__] years
141 Runnings of that race okay you don't
stay open by [__] paying out people
so you know I'm losing and I'm losing
and uh I find yourself [__] it I'll just
bet on the Derby race oh a lot of people
don't know this the races start at 10
30.
and they run them on the dirt track and
there's a grass track a little short
track
um they just you know they'll run like
six horses and uh if you thought it was
funny as if you're on the other side of
the track you can't even see the goddamn
race you just gotta watch it on TV which
once again
you're sitting there [__] getting
sunburned right like he came to this
country in a raft 20 minutes ago hoping
to get your [__] human rights
Tony Montana reference um
so anyways well you know I just let all
those ones go and um I went and I bet
the Derby race and uh I just picked
three favorites just trying to win some
money picks three favorites bet them
across the board two of them came in
um and I think I will what did I do I
think I lost like 25 bucks on the day
I was down like 50 or 60 bucks and in
the end I won like 30 something yeah
something like that but whatever it was
a [__] awesome time I would
definitely do it again I would say if
you go to the Derby race uh that's
actually that's a great thing to bring
your [__] lady to because it's a
sporting event you get to gamble
right you dress up she dresses up they
like dressing up right they look they
like the [__] horses right who
doesn't like animals
you know it doesn't like animals [__]
animals
animals don't like animals right they
don't they're self-loathing
how much you know they're always talking
about you know
how what [__] animals that human
beings act like what about the animals
the reference you know
you know what goes on in those woods in
those jungles you know what goes on
murder every [__] day
every goddamn day they're out there
[__] murdering people that's how they
get their food
you know they murder one another
I mean I'm actually presenting the
southern argument
basically uh supporting hunting all
right
I'll tell you what man if we didn't
shoot them they just [__] eat each
other so what's the point
I'm hungry too [__] what am I
supposed to do you
am I supposed to eat you
um oh one of the great heckles I ever
got I owe somebody apology in Evansville
Indiana
um the fun thing about when people text
during your show is like you know I
always have the crowd like I can see the
first few rows or whatever but then it
just kind of goes black so if somebody
starts texting their whole face lights
up when they're up there so you can see
it so I always freak people out I'll be
in the middle of my act and I'll just
see this light like 40 rows up but I'll
just point right at them and I go
texting
you know and I do this little Rift about
the person dying of thumb cancer because
they can't put their phone down right
so uh
so whatever in the middle of my show in
Evansville I'm having a great [__]
time it's the last night at the tour
uh you know
we're gonna go [__] oh I still explain
why I'm in Columbus Indiana
um I'll explain that a little bit right
so I'm gonna get wine in it down getting
towards the end of my act and this
person's I see this person's face light
up 40 [__] rows up and I go texting
and I start doing my little riff about
thumb cancer and
um
the guy ends up going
he yells out after I finished it my
whole long Soliloquy about this person
texting right and he goes uh he just
yells out I was taking your picture you
[__] dick
[Music]
oh my God taking your picture [__]
dick
and uh I forget what I said to him but I
was wrong it's like all right you just
and I go well you're not supposed to I'm
going to hang out after the show you can
do it then I kind of wear my way out of
him instead of being like oh you know
what sir I was wrong I thought you were
texting you were actually taking my
picture meaning you obviously were
having a good time with the show I was
in the wrong I owe you an apology I'm
sorry instead I just said well yeah
you're not supposed to
and that was like two two days ago but I
just keep thinking of that that's been
making me laugh
for two days you know like when somebody
just said something It just strikes you
as funny like for two days it just keeps
popping in your head
you know what I mean and people think
you're weird because you just burst out
laughing out of nowhere I've been doing
that for two days
I just went over to a waffle house I'm
on the road cut me some slack right and
I [__] go over there I've been in the
middle I'm up sitting at the counter
you know it's like elbow to Elbow
because it's a Sunday here when I'm
recording this
um and I'm sitting next to this [__]
guy and out of nowhere I you know
I didn't know what I was doing I think I
already ordered my stupid dinner my
breakfast and I just heard this guy's
voice taking your picture you [__]
dick I just burst it out laughing I kind
of weirded out the guy next to me like
why is this guy laughing is he laughing
at me is he a [__] problem yeah what
um so I apologize to that guy you were
right I was wrong and then also I want
to thank you for probably you know I
don't think you're sitting around still
laughing at my Act
uh you've making me laugh for 48 hours
I'm sure you weren't laughing at my act
after I trashed you for texting you took
you took it really personally
taking a picture you [__] dick
um
that was great don't do that in Alabama
don't say that in Alabama I'm pegging
your pet you [__] dick and then my
other favorite one was uh
was in Mobile I was doing some bit about
something dumb that I did I said can you
believe that why the [__] would I do
that and hear this guy go [__]
dumbass
needless to say oh freckles had a great
time
um I didn't even talk about Louisville
Kentucky man we had
oh [__] I'm so glad I didn't forget oh
let me let me do the Columbus thing
[__] add kicking in here
um
how I ended up in Columbus Indiana is
basically because all the hotels
anywhere near Louisville
are sold out
um and we laid I mean I got the tickets
and I waited till last second to get a
[__] room so we had like a 75 mile
round trip Drive
and uh you know we all kicked in for a
car service you know it wasn't that bad
at the end of the day and uh it was
great door-to-door service so we could
get all Wicked
um
so anyways uh
one of the coolest things ever okay so
we're going to Lexington Kentucky
and as I I mentioned slash threatened
that I was possibly considering when I
was in Lexington Kentucky wearing my
Kentucky Derby outfit on stage
and uh which was basically a seersucker
suit
with uh a pink and baby blue bow tie
with silly Canadians fan [__] socks
to match I I only apology to the Habs
fan too I like silly socks who knew a
Bruins fan I gotta admit silly sucks are
fun and you know who likes them the
[__] ladies
um oh look at those those are cute
and I known back when I was a single man
I'll tell you right now if you're in a
dry spell right now and you're not
[__] getting [__] I'm telling you
sorry to be graphic ladies [__] go
get yourself some silly socks and just
stick your foot on something that's a
little higher than your other foot and
you'll show it off and they'll come
walking up to you
they'll Strike It Up women cannot resist
a fashion statement
I'm telling you there's something about
not all of them but I'm telling us
something about it now I understand
those Frenchies and why they have those
[__] menage a trois it's not because
they're they're more schooled
in the language you love it's those
[__] sucks
which is smart right you get them
looking down at your ankles because you
don't have deodorant you have [__]
armpits
oh Jesus Bill what is wrong with you oh
[__] you you fill an hour every [__]
week
um
anyways oh okay I'll tell you the
Lexington uh story
uh right after these messages here and I
don't have my advertising yet so I'm
gonna have to drop these in so if it
sounds different that's why so let's
take a moment right now to listen to
Bill Burr in the future struggle his way
through the copy of some advertising for
this week
oh it's
oh it's Sizzlers
speak louder than words Mother's Day is
this weekend it is officially last
minute [__] not sure how to put
your thanks into words this Mother's
Days Mother's Day swizzler speaks louder
than words freshly dripped
dips berries with decorative Swizzles
this Mother's Day you know what to say
in your heart here is how to say it out
loud show your mom you love her
with the gift from Shari's Berries for
my listeners only
Sherry's Berries is offering
giant freshly dipped strawberries
starting at 1999 over 40 percent savings
and for my listeners you can double the
berries for just ten dollars more but
you have to use my code b-u-r-r
berries dipped in white milk and dark
chocolatey goodness topped with
chocolate chips nuts and decorative
swizzle
choose from berries cake truffles
brownie pops oh Jesus pretzels and more
you just need my Coke Burr when you
order giant fresh juicy delicious
tell a personal story I don't have one
here's the only way to get this amazing
deal freshly dipped strawberries
starting in 1999 over a 40 saving this
is this offer is on for my listeners
only when you're into my code burp Burr
visit berries
b-e-r-r-i-e-s.com click on the
microphone on the top right hand corner
and type in burp Burr go to berries.com
click on the microphone and enter my
code Burr
um meundies me undies no more sweaty
balls me undies
um it's good if you're gonna sprawl
spread your [__] sweaty legs put on
this underwear
and it dries out your balls I don't know
what you want from me it's [__] me
undies yeah oh yeah ninety percent
that's the [__] percent of your life
sorry guys I just got off a plane and I
had a couple of [__] cocktails ninety
percent that's the percent of your life
that you're in your underwear
and you wonder where it gets old fast
you know that feeling of putting on old
saggy underwear you need to know that
feeling of great fitting underwear that
is two times softer than cough cotton
you need to know about me undies me
undies no more sweaty balls or clams
even if you're a [__] transsexual and
you got all the goods none of it will be
sweaty yeah there you go Bruce Jenner
put this [__] on you [__]
meanders
[Applause]
it's the most comfortable underwear you
will ever wear and it's insane how good
they make your balls your dick and
possibly of a JJ Phil they make you feel
they feel great they fit perfectly they
don't ride up on you and they literally
pull moisture gross
um away from your skin so you stay stay
cool I have mine on right now and I'm
floating
half of that has to do with the [__]
cocktails
got bumped up to First Class there uh
they have cool stuff they cool styles
cool Styles me and for both men and
women and all look great check out the
photos yourself beyondes.com this
quality would typically retail for two
times Beyond his price according to me
undies no retail middlemen means more
savings for you oh yeah here I'll make
it easy
go to meundies.com
and get 20 off your first order and free
shipping save
even more when you buy a pack of them
they guarantee you're going to be happy
with them or your first pair is free
all right last one in this little chunk
here all right Dollar Shave Club
everybody you have heard me talking
about dollarshaveclub.com the company
that delivers amazing races
for a few bucks I know a razor that cost
a few bucks delivering a great shave
seems too good to be true right but you
really have to try the razors the
dollarshaveclub.com razors give me the
most amazing shape I've had in years for
the price don't pay triple the price
when you get a fan when you can get a
fantastic shave I get the hiccups
delivered
for just a couple of dollars
let me tell you something you'd have to
be a [__] idiot to keep over paying
I'm a semi
known person and I'm constantly getting
my picture taken by some [__] animal
outside of a bar
and I'm on TV shows in high definition I
can't be seen with Nixon Cuts all over
my face I have to shave with a high
quality razors don't be fooled by the
price these razors are legit two legit
to Legit to Quit come on now and you'll
never go back plus they also got Dr
kavi's easy shave butter
[__] butter it's phenomenal
if you're still using old-fashioned
shave foam you're a [__] loser and I
feel bad for you drive
dollarshaveclub.comrr to get started
today to get started you wish you had
started sooner that's
dollarshaveclub.com
Dollar Shave
club.com slash Burr
oh yeah
how do I shut this off
hey and I'm back I'm back and it's
[__] yesterday or maybe earlier today
depending on whenever I get the [__]
advertising
um anyways let's get back to uh oh this
is a good way for me to not to [__]
get off track here is to not read
advertising just plow through this [__]
um so I'll actually come back out of the
advertising and give you the Lexington
story
so here you go so
I'm sitting there I'm getting ready for
the show and I'm ironing my regular
shirt and everything and I'm thinking I
should wear the Kentucky Derby outfit
then I think what if they don't like it
and then I'm standing there it looks
stupid
and I was just like yeah don't be a
[__] put the [__] thing on so
I put the whole thing on right
and I'm standing backstage and I'm
waiting to go on
um after version law had killed it
lawhead's hosting so he's about ready to
bring me up
and for the first time since I can
remember I was actually a little nervous
just walking out to do a regular show
you know
um you know if it's [__] special or
something like that you always get the
butterflies
um and I was actually nervous so he
introduced please welcome Bill Burr so I
come walking out and everybody's
clapping and as they're clapping
they're taking in what the [__] I'm
wearing right and uh they went [__]
nuts they all stood up
it was one I gotta tell you I gotta
thank people next thing that is that's
the coolest Round of Applause I ever got
in my life I've never heard a crowd
cheer like that it was a different thing
it wasn't that was funny or I relate to
that that was uh
I can't explain it like it was it was
it made the [__] tour really made the
tour and then it was funny now I'm
standing there I got this outfit on and
then it dies down I go into my act and
that just became even funnier like oh
he's just gonna do his act dress like
like he's uh competing with Popeye's
Chicken here and um
I toughed it out for a good 10 minutes
before I finally had to take the hat off
I'm like you guys I gotta tell you this
this seemed like a great idea 90 seconds
ago but this [__] thing is hot as
hell under these lights so I ended up
taking off the hat but uh anyways we um
we ended up hanging out in Lexington
Kentucky and it was uh
it was uh just ridiculously polite
people we were right on the campus of
the Kentucky Wildcats and um
I mean it wasn't just me even uh law
ahead and Virgie were both just really
blown away at how great
the people were in Kentucky you know um
just really really
just nice polite smart people we were
right there on the [__] campus or
whatever
what are you saying we weren't smart and
intelligent you [__] dick
in Evansville I'm just saying you know
was it different by each one had a
different vibe like I liked Evansville
and everyone was [__] on Evansville
saying what a [__] it was
and uh I don't know I just have a
different perspective living in a state
that is running out of water
you know that is overly populated living
in a city that's actually a desert but
for some reason doesn't look like it
because we steal the water and everybody
freaking the [__] out like Captain Kirk
there actually having the balls to say
that Seattle has too much water it's
like oh really
oh did nature [__] that up did God put
the water in the wrong place shatny
um
Bill Shetty Oh Billy shad
it's like no we've been stealing the
water at some point the check was going
to hit the table right it's time to pay
up who knows what's going to happen do
you realize I just [__] put in one of
the great bathrooms of all time in Los
Angeles and it might not have a drop
coming out of the spicket
whose fault is that I knew it was a
desert you know
you got to know when to hold them
know when not to build a bathroom
especially when you live in a desert
that steals some water
don't act like a victim even though
you're a captain of a spaceship that was
a long [__] time ago and that
spaceship wasn't real
um
sorry
anyways
um
so
so we go to the derby the Derby ends now
we're driving back
you know everybody's starting to nod off
or whatever
and uh we [__] get back here to
Columbia Indiana and we're all excited
because we're gonna go watch
the uh Mayweather Pacquiao fight we're
gonna watch game seven and then watch
May wear the Pacquiao fight oh by the
way I was wrong
about the uh my Red Wings pick
congratulations to the Tampa Bay
Lightning for closing out that series
and then I also said that the Spurs
were going to beat uh the Clippers I I
said the Spurs once the Clippers lost
game two I was like that [__] series
is over it's the Clippers they don't
have it in them the Spurs know how to
win it's the first round they're gonna
[__] get past them shows you what the
[__] I know once again shows you what
the [__] I know which also begs the
question why the [__] are you still
listening to this
um
we end up going into uh the Buffalo Wild
Wings up the street oh yeah oh yeah the
Buffalo Wild Wings and uh turns out they
don't have to fight
we're like what do you mean you don't
have the fight
it's the biggest [__] fight of the
last 10 goddamn years in boxing
how do you not have the fight
Mr Wild Wings can I call you Buffalo
hey Buffy why don't you have the [__]
fight right
well we walk in there and within two
seconds we realize why they don't have
the fight because it's an absolute [__]
show we walked into that [__] place
the Buffalo Wild Wings
um
and they had game seven up on the big
screen they had two big screens so up in
the big screen they have game seven
of the Spurs and the Clippers and next
to it they have another big screen and
on that they have some replay of a golf
tournament
and for whatever [__] reason when we
walked in the volume was up on the golf
tournament
to like like spinal tap 11.
I've never heard golf commentary that
loud in my life and meanwhile the Spurs
it was already the third quarter it was
just to start coming out of this coming
out of the half
it was like 54-52 something crazy like
that so I guess it was you know
you know quarter in mid mid third
quarter right
and we're sitting there
law ads immediately beside himself lad
used to manage a [__] restaurant so
we always walk in we get them going we
go Jay could you manage this version
always does this Hey Jake could you
manage this place and he goes like you
give me okay right now right now she'd
be fired and he just starts firing half
the staff it's just this [__] running
joke and we asked them about this place
so how would you manage this place he
said I boarded up and shut it down
called the [__] regional manager and
say we got to start over again so we say
to the waitress uh can
we put the uh game seven basketball fan
on or these you guys really into golf
here and she kind of laughs and yeah I
don't know why the volume's up on that
either so they switch it over to the
game
and we were watching the game still
beside ourselves that a Buffalo Wild
Wings for as much as you watch their
commercials like this is the place to go
to watch the game
everybody with their tall [__]
slender hoary looking glasses drinking
the Blue Moon with the orange in it
right having the best [__] time ever
watching the game telling a little petty
lies to their friends and their wives
and all this [__] because it's so great
isn't that also the one where you get to
hit pause so you can just make this
amazing experience continue even longer
I'll tell you right now man our
experience at the Buffalo Wild Wings
Applebee's could talk [__] the Buffalo
Wild Wings and you know when you go to
an Applebee's to watch a game you're
watching that on a square kitchen TV all
right it's stuck up next to some fake
brick you know as they bring in with one
of those hot skillets
of some [__] that they think is fancy
all right
those poor people nobody at Applebee's
is is progressed beyond the seventh
grade and that's a fact that's actually
one of the requirements to manage an
apple piece okay your grades have to
take a major dip in the seventh grade
lost all hope by the 10th grade
all right
anyways let's plow ahead here so anyway
so I'm sitting there going like wow
that's really [__] up that the Wild
Wings of Buffalo
um why is don't match this chicken wild
um
so anyways
I actually
went to look up uh
you know I don't know I was just reading
on the uh the Pacquiao oh wait wait wait
wait wait what the [__] am I talking
about so the [__] clip is ended up
beating the Spurs and one of the great
games I've seen in basketball in a while
and great series God knows the only
reason why I watched it because I was
hanging out with The Virginian lawhead
I've missed all the hockey as you can
tell I know Tampa Bay's up uh one game
to none on the Habs I know the Rangers
are up two nothing on the capitals
I think the Ducks won their first game
and I don't know what's going on with
Chicago
bull bill you could have looked it up
for the podcast hey you know what you
could do you could go [__] yourself you
could do a tofu maybe if I [__] this up
it makes you feel good because you get
to correct me on Twitter
um
anyway so I'll
um I ended up we came back
a crash inversy texted me like two hours
later and says I guess the uh
the Mayweather Pacquiao fight was a [__]
show it was boring as [__] and blah blah
what people were basically saying
and um so I was kind of looking it up
today to see what the deal was and you
know basically boxing purists or at this
point people who actually watch Boxing
were saying that it was a great fight
and that Mayweather once again pulled up
put on an absolute clinic and if you
actually knew your ass from a [__]
hole in the ground when it came to
boxing you would have actually been able
to see that and you wouldn't have been
piss moaning and complaining that it was
boring
you know which I understand because I
know when I watch UFC
which I don't know a lot about but I
watch it on TV and Rogan's always
describing oh the guy's going for a
Kimora he's going for this we're going
for that the crowd after wow starts to
boo
when they're laying on the ground
because they think it's boring
but you know in defense of those fans
when you sit in 200 rows up you can't
see what he's going for all right
looks like two people cuddling
um
but they can't quite get comfortable
they're a new couple you know what I
mean they're trying to see how the two
bodies fit together
so
um
anyways so I just started reading about
the fight to see what happens um I
actually had my wife pay for the fight
I'm gonna watch it tonight
um because at the very least when I
watch it it makes me want to get in
shape
um
oh which is a great thing to do by the
way if you hate skipping rope tape a
[__] championship fight that goes the
distance there you go
right then all you do is you press play
and when they fight you skip rope when
they sit down you sit down and then you
keep going you try to see how many
rounds you can go all right and as they
get tired you get tired you feel like
you're actually a fighter and then the
end of it you realize you just some jerk
off
in his in his underwear Skip and rope
right and it hurts when it hits your
toes
um all right so here's how the paper
I've actually looked up some [__] here's
how the pay-per-view worked out and I
own I own another apology to the Wild
Wings of Buffalo
God knows if you ever go out to Buffalo
you got to watch out for the for the not
the domesticated chicken it's the wild
chicken
all right
those [__] those [__] will take
you out man they'll jump right on the
hood of your car and they'll Peck
through your windshield and there's
nothing you can do one of them goes for
the electrical so you [__] you can't
start your car
right
and it's it's over it's like one of
those Alfred Hitchcock movies
chickens
um here's how the pay-per-view worked
for uh for bars or anybody basically
showing it at a commercial level that
was going to charge for the Manny uh uh
the Pacquiao and uh Mayweather fight
bars venues had to pay 25 times their
their fire code fire code being the
maximum amount of cable they can be in
the establishment
um so it's not a fire hazard so you had
to pay 25 times basically being sold out
so basically out of the gate
if the bar charged 25 ahead they needed
to sell out the bar just to break even
on what they paid for the fight this is
why boxing is so [__] dumb okay you
got a sport that is starting to lose to
the UFC or not starting to it has been
and this is what the [__] they do when
they got this great fight to maybe bring
the Casual fan back you know this is
what they do so if you had a bar that
was I actually worked out the numbers
250 capacity right that's the fire code
that would cost you six thousand two
hundred fifty dollars
to get the fight then if you charge 30
bucks ahead you try to make five ahead
if you sold out you'd make 12.50 you got
to spend 60 6 250 bucks to make one
thousand two hundred fifty bucks that's
if you [__] sold out
all right and there's nothing stopping
the guy across the street from also
having the fight or from people at home
going hey why don't we have [__] you
know five people watch it it'll cost us
20 bucks ahead so you're competing with
all of that there's nothing exclusive
about this this isn't like hey you know
[__] uh whatever Justin Bieber
[__] you he sells tickets is performing
at my venue and my venue alone tonight
now he's across the street he's [__]
everywhere right so Boston Boxing
basically said to these bars that we're
taking all the money
um
we're taking all the money from your
customers to watch the fight okay and
then you take the booze and the food it
was essentially like a door deal that
was based on the bar taking
responsibility to sell out their own
venue
how dumb is that
like not to mention these two guys
should have fought
five to seven years ago when they were
in their Prime I'm not saying they're
not great Fighters not the great
fighters of all [__] time I'm just
saying they should have fought
like in the 2000s it's 2015 they're
finally [__] fighting
um I just think I don't know boxing is
just it's just a really
poorly run [__] Sport and the fact
that Fighters can't Dodge one another
for so long I think that that's why
you don't have those great fighting
divisions anymore
like when I was growing up okay 70s and
80s when I was a kid and then getting
into my teenage years
boxing was unbelievable all right and
what happened with each decade was they
would just you know the planets aligned
and there'd be this ridiculous level of
talent
in one Division and then that was the
division you wanted to watch and then
like in the 70s it was the heavyweight
Division and then
in the 80s it was the middleweight
Division and meanwhile there was all
these other divisions that had like
Alexis arguella and Boom Boom Mancini
and all these these Superstars
but I think a guy like
you know like nowadays then I began to
dump but back then it was just what was
it the WBA the wbf was all it was then
it was a wbf and the WBA and the ibf and
that would be like the NFL split into
[__] three football leagues
it you know and each one of them had a
Super Bowl champion it [__] the whole
thing up
and then all of a sudden the UFC comes
along you got everybody under the one
umbrella and even some of the other
groups
like UFC's doing exactly what the NFL
and the NBA did like when the the ABA or
the uh the AFL came out the NFL just
absorbed that League
the NBA absorbed the ABA the league was
you know that upstart League was then
over and then they had just had a
monopoly so then the best football team
or the best basketball team has to play
the second best one and then that's the
champion
[__] boxing hasn't been like that
forever so
I think that that's why
I think Mayweather suffers because of
that
even though he wouldn't probably
wouldn't be undefeated because
Mayweather fought
back
in that division when Hagler Hearns Ray
Leonard
Durand if all of those guys had losses
because they all had to [__] fight
each other and nowadays it's like you
know [__] you watch Mayweather and
Pacquiao for [__] seven years before
they finally [__] fight I know a lot
of you guys say Bill you don't know [__]
about fighting I admit that
okay but if you want to survive as a
[__] League or as a division or
whatever the [__] your sport is you got
to get the [__] like me to buy the
fight the Casual fan who says dumb [__]
and the person who actually watches it
sits there and rolls their eye I know
the feeling I go to Super Bowl parties
right
I just don't understand why the [__]
they're doing that because boxing is
such an unbelievable sport
um
the only thing that does bug me about it
is I am a hockey fan and I hate when
they talk about the fighting how they
got to get the fighting out of hockey
it's really but you really you got to
get the fighting out of hockey but but
you don't have to get the fighting out
of boxing
you know what I mean that's all they do
is punch each other in the [__] head
to the point that they end up with
Parkinson's disease
[__] hockey they occasionally fight
it's a little spiced it's a little
[__] flavor to the game
all these [__] people can't handle it
don't [__] watch it ah Jesus bill you
just did the sporting version of if you
don't like it lunch get the [__] out of
the country taking your picture you
[__] dick
take a picture [__] dick
um
the more exaggerated the more the more
it just keeps giving oh it's the joke
that just keeps giving all right let's
do uh let's do some questions here but
um
having said all that who the [__]
wouldn't want to be in the shape of
Mayweather or [__] Pacquiao good Lord
the [__] dedication alone that just
that takes forget about the fact that
you have to push down the sick and
sickening nauseating feeling that there
is a World cast class athlete training
somewhere in the universe to just beat
the living [__] out of you
I mean that's just [__] unreal you
know I mean if you're gonna get into a
fight don't you want just just to happen
like you know you just sit there and all
of a sudden you're [__] yelling at
somebody at the Kentucky Derby that just
[__] happens but if you have to sit
there and think about it and train for
it and know that somebody else is going
to do it that's just the level of balls
that I obviously
the old freckled Wonder here I I can't I
can't relate to that
um all right so here we are this is the
money money podcast everybody and uh I
do this once a week and once a week I
got the uh just checking in on you
podcast on Thursday
the Tuesday afternoon just before Friday
Monday Morning podcast
um
that's the one I just sort of that's a
newer one I just do like 30 minutes and
then I play some classic hits
from uh from Years Gone by in another
world where podcasting was young
it was innocent and it was Unified
unlike boxing
um if you'd like me to uh talk about
something or whatever if you want to
suggest some topics the way to do it for
the Thursday one is you tweet at uh bill
at the mmpodcast.com which with the
hashtag
t-a-m-m-p all capitals Tango Alpha Mike
Mike Papa sorry
um
and for the Monday morning podcast if
you'd like me to read your emails your
questions or whatever
um just send it to
oh I'm such a dope bill at the
mmpodcast.com is the email for Mondays
I've never gotten this [__] right
all right [__] everything that I just
said
[__] a dickish
um all right
for the Thursday afternoon Monday
Morning podcast just before Friday
all right hashtag t-a-m-m-p and the
Twitter account is at the mm podcast
all right good Lord
now if you want to email me for the
Monday Morning podcast it's bill at
themmpodcast.com
Jesus Christ Bill
that was all written right in front of
me and I still [__] it up
um for the Thursday one you can tweet
articles videos questions
um
I guess you know what you don't need to
tweet at the mm podcast you can just
hashtag Jesus here's the third version
you can just hashtag
t-a-mmp oh [__]
ah Jesus Christ
that I mean that was just
if anybody has a business school and you
want to teach about what not to do in
advertising why don't you just play that
clip
all right under the slide caption [__]
show
all right
Evansville here's something greetings
Bill I just wanted to take a moment to
thank bill for an incredible show in
Evansville Indiana thank you very much
I'm actually upset when we've rode into
town I didn't get to go to the uh the
cross-eyed grasshopper
Family Restaurant I mean with the
[__] name like that how do I not go
in there
and eat amongst those water bugs I'm
kidding I'm sure it's a nice clean
friendly place I said my face still
hurts from laughing also I was wondering
what were the names of the two opening
acts
uh they were both great well that would
have been Paul verzi
v-i-r-z-i and Jason lawhead spelled like
law break the law
and head I'll kick in the [__] head
why can't it be something nice okay I
will
fix the cowlick on top of your head
gently
as I stare at your eyes
um
stare at your eyes look romantically oh
[__] forget it all right Thursday
podcast
um hey Bill on the old clips uh you
talked about an urban legend
oh yeah I was talking about all those
urban legends about you remember Pop
Rocks Don't there was a kid and he he
ate a whole bot he sucked down a whole
package of Pop Rocks in his [__]
stomach exploded and there was always
the one about dude there was a kid would
be putting he put an M80 which is an
eighth of a stick of dynamite I believe
we always thought it was a quarter stick
I think it's an eighth
stuck in the back of some kid's pocket
lit it and uh blew half the kid's ass
off so this guy says um
well in the mid 80s my brother my
stepbrother did just that he had to get
skin grafted from his thigh
to his ass it's no urban legend from New
Jersey
oh maybe that's where it started they
always say there's a little bit of Truth
in all of that [__] is that what they
say that is what they say two Billy holy
[__] the Thursday podcast is the best
thing you could have done you are a
genius I'm not a genius Andrew came up
with it uh the old clips are hilarious I
love dropping in on the middle of an old
school podcast catching you in a random
mood yeah that is the thing because my
vibe on this Thursday then it connects
with whatever the [__] I was talking
about on some Monday in like 2009 or 10
or something so I guess that would be a
weird little mashup as the kids say
um this person said I listened to a lot
of podcasts over time some of them
changed the hosts get egos
and the vibe is different I love how
you're 10 times bigger than you were
when you oh look at this whole [__]
ball rubbing thing here
did I write this
I'm 10 times bigger than I was everybody
when I started the podcast but I still
act the same old freckles is down there
well when you're a balding red-headed
male you really don't have the
opportunity to take your shirt off and
VIP do you huh spinning around your head
I swear to God if I had pigment I would
be a much
oh my God the ego I would [__] have
are you kidding me if I had pigment a
full head of hair you guys wouldn't even
know me
um the day that they actually come up
with a pill
because I would never do that [__]
you know
taking hair from the back of your
[__] head put on I would never do
that but I'm not I'm not [__] doing
that
numbing up my head it's just like all
right though Phil why don't you just
admit that it's over
all right
[__] buzz it down grow some sort of
facial hair you know or just shave your
face and let people look like a just
make them look at a rapidly approaching
50 year old adult baby
how mad
don't do this by the way because you'll
get in trouble but how [__] funny and
how mad would the person get if you
walked up to a [__] guy
who had his head clean-shaved at his
face he didn't have any facial hair all
right and he's in his 40s or whatever he
just walked up to him he's sitting in a
bar minding his own business and he
walked up and you're underneath this
genuine Gucci Gucci goo
uh Gucci
like how far could you get away before
that person
I think I would well no somebody
touching you would make you mad
other than that I mean I think I'd laugh
um but don't do that everybody
okay the world is is a bad enough place
you really don't need
you know you know do you really need a
bar fight
think about that people
at what point in you in your life do you
sit there and be like you know what
would be a good asset to my life right
now
both spiritually personally and legally
a nice knock down drag out bar fight
although that would be funny though if
that happened and then you guys actually
decided to work it out on like Judge
Judy
you know and she comes out there all
[__] extra angry for the [__] uh
you know for the TV cameras
and you went out there and that you know
the bald guys got to go uh you know
it's minding me on business and just
might come up I put his finger Charlie
bit my finger and it hurt he put it on
under me cheek
and what did he say at that time
uh he said a coochie coochie coop
right and I didn't like it
I don't like it to be English
oh whatever the [__] I was just trying
to do
right there's no robbery I gotta get
back to [__] peaky blinders when I
get back on two episodes and I'm gonna
watch every [__] episode I can before
I go to do all my shows in Boston there
um all right
what else was there uh thanks for the
laugh man my days go by much quicker no
worries everybody look at that the
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday Morning podcast the just checking
in on your podcast to make it [__]
quicker is really look at people are
liking it check it out if you can
um oh [__] all right I gotta read
another advertising here before I get
into the rest of these uh once again
this is Bill Burr in the future
desperately trying to read out loud
my Jesus we're back in the past there
actually when you're listening to all of
this it's all in the past isn't it
I don't know all right booing at the
draft from a lady hey Bill my
mother-in-law is a huge sports fan and
she insisted on watching the draft I
have never seen the draft before and I
was really shocked at the rude behavior
of the spectators well you've obviously
never gone to a sporting event going to
a sporting event is watching a bunch of
people that probably can't catch a ball
or maybe they could but now
they're just old and out of shape just
you know just trashing people that can
do what they they could never do
that's what it is
um anyways is that how it normally goes
down or is it because it was held in
Chicago as a Wisconsin night
I would have thought it was a
wisconsinor a wisconsinite
that lives in a tourist destination for
those damn
fibs
[__] idiot bastards
oh [__] Illinois bastards oh I came
close
uh as we call them in door con Door
County
I instantly blame Chicago for all the
ass Hattery are my instincts correct or
is it always like that thanks and go
[__] yourself
um no your instincts are not correct and
as far as
uh wisconsinites view people from
Chicago you know that's just standard
Behavior that's standard human behavior
you don't like your neighbor you don't
like your neighbor
this town is Rivals with the town next
to it
this state doesn't like the state next
to it this country doesn't like the
country next to it you just keep making
it bigger and bigger this continent
doesn't like this continent you can go
right up just basically familiarity
breeds contempt
and it takes an unbelievable level of
maturity for you to be sitting up there
in cheese land to look down at mustache
City and see the good in it
you know especially when they're coming
up there to vacation in in your area
you're not gonna like it when I lived in
New York City I [__] hated walking
through Times Square
bunch of [__] families with their
kids going to the [__] Eminem store
you know they actually made you wish
that it was still peep shows which was
disgusting it was [__] gross Times
Square back in the day was gross and now
they've gone the other way which just uh
you know it's a lot of uh big people and
jean shorts
plotting through traffic not knowing
where they're going
and there's nothing like a giant a giant
group of people likes to do more than to
just stop and stand in the middle of the
sidewalk looking around waiting for
someone to make a [__] decision
you know
a bunch of followers
right walking into the Hershey Kiss
store
you know
buying some [__] New York t-shirt
that has [__] you know you buy the
New York T-shirt with a picture of John
Lennon on it wearing the New York
t-shirt you want to do that [__] yeah
you [__] hate that stuff so no I
don't think it has to do with that I
mean obviously you know Philly's known
for booing
uh New York City is known for booing
Boston's known for you know
it's a yeah you know it's a [__] and
people also fly in for the draft
if you can believe that
they fly in for the draft
uh I will never understand that I
already did a bit about it on my last
special but I I will never understand
that
it's like going down to the DMV when you
don't have to
someone's going to take the test for you
all you got to do is just see how they
did the next day as you're reading a
[__] English muffin there's no
[__] reason to go down there
um
I haven't even looked I haven't even
stopped to even look to see you know who
my team took
um
and I don't give a sh I mean I care I
want them to do well but like I'll wait
to the football season to see how they
do
but I guess those are the people that
get into it a lot more you know the ones
that want to
those of people actually know the names
of like the GM's and the higher-ups and
like I I just don't have [__] time to
get into it to that level you know what
I mean I I have too many other things
that waste my time
um so no I wouldn't blame it on Chicago
I like Chicago I love Wisconsin I think
you guys are all great standing from the
outside I don't know what your [__]
problem is the same way I look at the
Middle East what is the [__] problem
over there why don't you all guys if
everybody just became atheist in the
Middle East you know ah they'd find
something else
I don't like his shoes let's blow them
up
um game show
uh Bill if you could be on any game show
from any time period oh what a great
question what would it be I'm a huge
back in the day I was a big game show
fan when I was growing up during the
summer we didn't have a pool right we
lived on a busy street we used to watch
the prices right every day
is that the one
well the thinking music
on the match games
with the [__] Wawa pedal was big in
the 70s all right
um
let's see I picture you on The Price is
Right good call
God knows you're not cut out for
Jeopardy [__] you or Wheel of Fortune
kidding you're a smart bass no I'm not
on a wheel of fortune dude you can have
everything but the vowels and I still
can't get it
um I'm really bad at that like as you
see I'm not good at reading out loud I'm
not good at reading in general
everything gets all jumbled up you know
my eyes travel faster than my brain can
process it it's an absolute [__] show uh
he goes I see you teaching old ladies
how to put
and demonstrating what how to putt and
demonstrating the wheel going around
oh yeah I thought you meant as a
contestant you're talking about hosting
all right or uh demonstrating the wheel
going around one full rotation and not
to mention the kisses on the cheek from
all the [__] ladies and instead of
Barker's Beauties it'd be burst Beauties
your thoughts all right if I could host
any show
um I kind of like the Family Feud but
there's two you gotta talk to too many
people
I'd rather just deal with the head of
both families like a mob thing like
let's have a little [__] sit down all
right you know you seem like a
reasonable person but you know that [__]
show behind you I really don't want to
get involved in so why don't you ask
them what the [__] they think and then
you say it how about that
all right so I would not last long on
that uh Wheel of Fortune
um
I could actually I wouldn't mind hosting
that one the sound of the wheel is
annoying to me
I don't like when they [__] lose a
turn they go beep that will get to me
after a while because I would think like
that would be the the soundtrack to my
career at that point
although Vanna White's still there still
looking on
you know she threw me a glance with
those beautiful [__] eyes that could
be a fun one uh Price is Right I mean
that's the iconic one I mean that's the
[__] Patriots that's the Yankees as
much as I hate to say the Canadians and
game shows right it is
[__] is actually to be fair it's the
Green Bay Packers
because they've won the most NFL titles
in Super Bowls combined I would have to
say that so uh
Price is Right
I you know I like about the Price Is
Right is you're not confined to just one
game
you know I mean like Wheel of Fortune is
the one game the spinning the wheel
spinning the wheels spinning the wheel
[__] Family Feud I asked you uh name
a sound of a fart
and you said
survey said
you know whatever I think you're just
doing the same thing [__] over and
over again right
but the price is right there's all those
different games
all the different games and then you
know you got a half time like a sporting
event I think you nailed it dude
remember card sharks
all of it higher
all of it lower
it's [__] stupid it's really hard you
know if you can come up with a good game
show
one of the most brilliant ones ever was
Who Wants to Be a Millionaire
that's such a [__] simple idea I
can't believe I didn't [__] thing to
do that
shows someone be hosting this podcast
right now I'd be drinking myself to
death somewhere on a [__]
I don't know what not an island
I'd be getting psych die of sunstroke I
don't know where the [__] I'd be if I
wouldn't be sitting here right now
Who Wants To Be A Millionaire hey who
doesn't I mean right there [__] show
sells itself
I know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna come
up with a game show for like the porno
Network called who wants a [__]
show
then you just ask like [__] questions
about uh you know whatever sex
rim job is that your final answer
Finance your rim job you are correct
um all right let's move on to the next
one all right woman takes man's leg
okay
hey Bill I'm I am 19 years old oh by the
way I'm really happy that a [__]
woman finally wrote in here hey Bill I
am 19 years old just graduating high
school and not going and going to enlist
in the U.S Marine Corps uh just a little
about me in parentheses I've been
listening to your podcast for about a
year now and I find you hilarious
anyways I came across this video and
apparently this lady
steal this steals this guy's leg when he
goes to sleep and has been holding it
for ransom because this guy cheated on
her
I just wanted to get your take on this
since you're the best on discussing the
ladies thanks for all the laughs and go
[__] yourself
so wait a minute this guy's got a fake
leg
obviously no bill he's got a real one
and she sought it off and [__] I
don't know
what do they do then they stick you
stump in a fire that's how they used to
do it in the uh
the cowboy movies to cauterize whatever
their [__] word is clarify your
[__] arteries
I don't know stop the bleeding does that
even work or is that just some Hollywood
[__] I have no [__] idea
I don't pretend to be a doctor or even
look like one
um what do I think about that well he
[__] around hell half no fury
well how long has she had the leg
you know what I would do I just buy
another one I'd light up my car
I'd buy another one and I would [__]
you know walk awkwardly over to her
house and I would just be like really
you know what do I think about that I
think uh she should give it back
I understand why she [__] did it but
um that's that [__] that women can
get away with where they can get away
with destruction of property and that
type of [__] like
you know they can throw all your [__]
out the [__] window light it on fire
and do all this type of crap and the
cops show up just laughing
you know I've been there I [__] around
on my girl I got a dick too buddy this
is what happens every once in a while
they like their [__] on fire oh she's
like a [__] alley cat and a [__]
[__]
um what do I think about it I think it's
[__] hilarious he obviously uh you
know
he [__] around what are you gonna do
don't get mad about that
you gotta I would I would think that if
I had a fake leg
and I was [__] around that uh I would
be wearing that thing to bed
you know what I mean or at least I'd
have a backup like I think in general
wouldn't you have a backup leg
I mean even people who can't see got a
backup pair of glasses right
should have another leg
you know what you have a [__] egg you
know you know how many cell phone
charges I have I [__] lose those
things all the time
and I know what people would know with
only one leg are thinking dude you have
any idea how expensive they are no I got
both my legs but I can tell you this I
cut back on the drinking to have a spare
you know what I mean
I'd be still watching a square TV before
I would buy a flat screen okay I
wouldn't buy a flat screen TV until I
had an extra [__] leg that that's a
that's a [__] guarantee okay you can
take that to the goddamn Bank
all right but you know let's get to the
real story here let's talk about this
[__] Mack Daddy who only has one
goddamn leg and he's still [__]
slaying it
you know
I bet that got her [__] goat
the fact that you know this guy's got
one leg and she's sitting there patting
herself on the back of what a good
person she is that she's you know that
she can see I don't care about
appendages
I care I care about what's in here
now what's hanging off your pelvis
except for that your dick you know
um but who knows maybe Bruce Jenner
doesn't want his maybe well I should
test maybe he could buy his
shirt's a little bit older than you are
but you know I mean decathlons is your
[__] one
I'm not trying to belittle you I am not
don't put words in my mouth
um
yeah I I she's you know
that's [__] hilarious
I can't come into work today why well I
[__] around on my girlfriend she took
my fake leg
all you're gonna hear is the boss
on the other side [__] you
what are you gonna do buddy hop down
here and kick my ass you're gonna fall
down
um anyways all right so I'm sure you're
going to hear from the people with one
[__] leg out there you know
quit your bitching okay
can always be worse
all right it can always be [__] worse
you know what I mean for every person
out there with one leg all right there's
someone else in a Loveless marriage okay
and that's even worse
every [__] day
waking up
next to that person man or a woman and
not feeling a [__] thing
as they look into your eyes and they
hand you that card on Valentine's Day
you might as well be talking to a chest
of drawers
um all right wow that was dark all right
Gathering and protesting versus rioting
bill
I sympathize with the black community
through all of this oh God this sounds
like it's going to go off the rails hey
I have a black friend
but having said that
um
all right it's ridiculous uh some cops
not all of them can be total [__]
with pent up anger and absolutely no
control over their violent actions and
it's no excuse you shouldn't have to do
that job unless you're a saint who also
knows how to kick ass
[__] hilarious you want a superhero
at that point where do you stand on the
protests slash riots Where's the Line
obviously destroying someone's business
is ridiculous and doesn't promote social
change but I also sometimes
he just he misses a word but also
sometimes think I think he was supposed
to say you gotta crack a few eggs please
use the next five to ten minutes to
solve this social problem hilarious
um I don't know when I watch that you're
just watching the results of uh
you know
what happened a long time ago
it's the Fallout of all of that
um
The Genius of uh saying that one race
was better than another race so you
could [__] over both races but you
adjusted how you were doing it and you
get to keep all the money at the top
right like you're basically stick in a
dick in everybody's ass but you go balls
deep with one people and in other people
you're only halfway in and then you get
so then the genius of that is you got
someone with half a dick in their ass
actually feeling lucky because it's not
balls deep right
and just the fall out of that is what
you're watching does that make any sense
other than I can't just totally blame
super rich people on this so the
controlling people throughout the
centuries but I will say that uh just
generally speaking even that horseshit
with the lady in Wisconsin just looking
for the bad and Chicago people and
blaming all of the [__] behavior on
uh
draft day for the city of Chicago
um I just think unfortunately
the inherent nature of people is to uh
be selfish to be fearful to want more to
be worried about tomorrow and uh to want
to be uh
I don't know feel a little better
than the other person I mean look at me
at the Derby right
now where I was seating I was two steps
above where those people were standing
and when I stood up I could still see
the [__] race but I was like I am a
sitter you are a stander you are less
than me and next thing you know I'm
yelling at this person like I built the
whole [__] area right I just think
it's in our nature to not get along I
hate to say that because it's the
easiest [__] thing to do because it
doesn't take any effort
getting annoyed by somebody is
effortless actually having empathy and
seeing where the [__] they're coming
from or maybe thinking about how you
should say something and respecting
somebody it just takes a lot of [__]
effort you know
and you know In the Heat of the Moment
that usually doesn't happen and uh there
you go
I overly simplified the whole [__]
thing but I think it's uh
I don't know I've been through Baltimore
I've been through
Detroit
parts of Cleveland parts of Buffalo all
that Rust Belt and stuff they you know
parts of the South now some of the
places I went through you can't believe
how people are living in this country
and it's just [__] wrong
it's wrong and then we're over there
allegedly trying to rescue people in
other countries which is the dumbest
[__] ever it isn't we're just taking
their natural resources making I mean we
are
I don't get into all of that [__] but I
just don't think that this country is
sitting there looking at other countries
going God damn it
[__]
they're just not free
we got to do something about this it's
[__] I don't I don't buy into any of
it it's uh
you know and this is another thing too I
have no [__] idea how to turn that
around
no [__] way I turn it around on a
societal level I can't tell though on an
individual level uh you could totally
turn around your life without a [__]
doubt you just have to
[__]
you just can't you got to become
Unstoppable
and the more down the [__]
[__] slide you are the more Unstoppable
you have to [__] be and that's just
the way it is life isn't [__] Fair
and for as bad as you got it somebody's
got a [__] worse I mean there's a guy
with one [__] leg who can't go to
work
because he stuck his dick into something
else which he's [__] wired to do you
know I mean that woman taking that other
guy's leg she's basically saying God is
wrong you know
but she won't get called on it will she
did any of that make any sense I
actually started daydreaming halfway
through that
um
this is Bill Burr and this has been the
Monday Morning podcast I would like all
of you to go [__] yourselves and I'll
talk to you next I'll actually talk I'll
check in on you on Thursday but I'm
basically going to talk to you
I talk to you every Monday Thursdays I'm
just checking in on you you know I'm
just poking my head and seeing how the
[__] you're doing but this this day here
this is the real [__] right if you like
the real [__] and it is a pile of [__]
here and if you would like to uh
contribute to the Monday morning podcast
effortlessly well this actually takes a
little bit of [__] next time you go to
Amazon to buy something just click on go
to billboard.com click on the podcast
page and then just click on the Amazon
little [__] app there whatever the
[__] thing you call it the banner ad
it'll take you right to Amazon and then
buy something if you want and if you do
I get a little credit for driving some
traffic that was already going to go
there anyways they kicked me a little
bit of [__] money
um they're basically whoring off the
love that they think you have for me in
this podcast that's what they're doing
they're trying to pile on that [__]
you know what I mean
I don't know what I'm talking about
um thanks to everybody sincerely for the
last two weeks
um
I am wiped out I am tired but it was one
of the great experiences that I've had
in my stand-up career to get to go to
all these cities that I had never been
to
um other than New Orleans I had never
been to any of these other ones as far
as I can remember and it was awesome the
people were great the crowds were
awesome and uh